[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara
halallweg willkommen zum
Nachrichtenüberblick an diesem Sonntag
die vom Sport hat Norbert Lehmann ein
schönen guten Abend auch von mir und das
sind die Themen von
heute zwei Frauen für Europa die SPD
setzt bei der Wahl im Juni erneut auf
Katharina Bley die FDP schickt Mar Stck
Zimmermann ins
Rennen Betrug beim Waffenkauf 100.000
Mörsergranaten wie diese sind in der
Ukraine bezahlt aber nie geliefert
worden ranghohe Beamte machten mit und
turnierabschluss in Moll bei ihrer
heimem verpassen die deutschen
Handballer gegen Schweden Bronze und die
direkte Olympia
Qualifikation 2024 wird ein wichtiges
Wahljahr mit drei Landtagswahlen im
Herbst davor kommt im Sommer die
Europawahl dafür haben sich heute SPD
und FDP aufgestellt mit zwei
Spitzenkandidatinnen und einer
Kampfansage gegen Rechtspopulisten SPD
frontfraau Katharina Bley sprach von
einer Richtungswahl für Europa und
warnte vor Zitat neun Nazis Dorte fber
fast 99% der Stimmen hat sie bekommen
katharina barli ist erneut SPD
Spitzenkandidatin bei der Europawahl bei
der letzten Wahl gab es ein historisch
schwaches Ergebnis barali gibt sich
unverdrossen kämpferisch für die SPD und
vor allem für die Europäische Union und
da gibt's jetzt aber auch noch andere
die wollen noch mal eine ganz andere
Richtung einschlagen nämlich raus aus
der Europäischen Union was für ein
Wahnsinn sie würden damit in kürzester
Zeit die deutsche Wirtschaft in eine
schwere Notlage bringen trotz schlechter
Umfrage Werte auch für Olaf Scholz
persönlich setzt die SPD auf den Kanzler
als zweites Gesicht ihrer
europawahlkampagne
die stärkste Stimme Europas aber heute
schwach ein Infekt bremst Scholz
stimmlich aus die Europawahl ist für die
Bürger und Bürger dieses Landes eine
Chance ein klares Votum gegen Rechts
abzugeben die Europawahl ist eine Chance
das zu tun indem man demokratische
Parteien und nicht die Rechten wählt und
die beste Idee das zu tun ist die
älteste demokratische Partei zu wählen
auf eine Richtungswahl schwt die
Genossen im Saal ein hier kommt das an
das was wichtig ist an dem was Olaf
Scholz gesagt hat ist noch mal zu sagen
dass wir in Europa zusammenhalten mussen
ich glaube er reist in erster Linie mit
seiner Performance die eigenen
Mitglieder wach ein Wahlkampf gegen die
Feinde Europas will die SPD führen und
gegen ihre eigenen schlechten
Umfragewerte FDP Parteichef Lindner
warnte davor die Europawahl zum
Denkzettel für die etablierten Parteien
zu zu machen und die AFD zu wählen die
Wolle Europa zum Steinbruch machen die
Liberalen schicken Marie Agnes Strack
Zimmermann ins Rennen die eurofighterin
wie Lindner sie nennt Britta Bucholz
berichtet minutenlanger Applaus für die
Hoffnungsträgerin der Partei Marie Agnes
Stck Zimmermann sehen sie als stärkste
Waffe für ein gutes Wahlergebnis sie
gilt als streitbar unbequem deutlich der
Parteivorsitzende Kampfes
lustig sministerin ist vor ihr seiner
Zeit ins Europäische Parlament bzw in
die Kommission geflüchtet jetzt schicken
wir Marie Agnes hinterher Stck
Zimmermann ist bislang Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses im Bundestag
bekannt wurde sie auch durch ihre
Differenzen mit dem Kanzler in der
ukraineeptik deutliche Worte auch heute
die Spitzenkandidatin spricht sich für
eine europäische Armee aus Europa müsse
unabhängig sein auch
dass die Amerikaner für uns die
berühmten Kastanien aus dem Feuer holen
die Probleme sind doch vor unserer Tür
die Ukraine ist vor unserer Tür und
deswegen verdammt noch mal haben wir
endlich unsere Rolle zu spielen weltweit
die 65-Jährige erhält 90% der
Delegierten stimmen sie trifft den Nerv
ihrer Partei ich glaube es ist zum einen
ihre kernige Art sie nimmt kein Blatt
vor dem Mund sie sagt was sie denkt das
es eben kommt nicht nur bei den W gut an
sondern auch in der Partei sie als muss
ich s sagen Zugpferd alleine ist schon
sehr sehr wichtig nach vielen verlorenen
Landtagswahlen soll Stck Zimmermann es
nun bei der Europawahl richten so die
Hoffnung auch an diesem Wochenende
gingen wieder hunderttausende gegen
Rechtsextremismus auf die Straße in
Hamburg kam heute nach einer
polizeischätzung mindestens 60.000
Menschen zusammen um mit einem
Protestzug durch die Innenstadt gegen
die AFD zu demonstrieren aber auch in
vielen kleineren Städten wie hier in
Neumünster setzten viele ein Zeichen für
die
Demokratie der ukrainische Geheimdienst
hat neue Details zu einem
Millionenbetrug bei Waffengeschäften
aufgedeckt der Fall war im Dezember
bekannt geworden verwickelt sind mehrere
hochrangige Beamte im
Verteidigungsministerium und Manager
eines Lieferanten dem Bericht nach geht
es um Mörsergranaten im Wert von 40
Millionen Dollar die der Front dringend
gebraucht werden das Ministerium zahlte
doch die Munition wurde nie geliefert
Anne Brühl in Kiev was ist jetzt neu und
was bedeutet dieser Betrug für die
Ukraine dieser Fall ist ja einer von
mehreren Korruptionsfällen die im Umfeld
des
Verteidigungsministeriums bekannt wurden
er stammt aus dem Sommer 22 der damalige
Verteidigungsminister ist gar nicht mehr
im Amt es gab eine Festnahme bereits im
Dezember der jetzt wird gegen fünf
Männer ermittelt wegen Veruntreuung und
Unterschlagung einer wurde verhaftet als
er versucht hat das Land zu verlassen
die Botschaft hier die ist klar der
Kampf gegen die Korruption geht weiter
und er geht kompromisslos weiter heißt
es hier und das ist wichtig auch für die
Bevölkerung die ja sieht wie dringend
diese Munition an der Front gebraucht
wird und dann geht es aber auch um die
Zukunftsperspektive denn die Bekämpfung
der Option das ist ja eine der
Kernforderungen der Europäischen Union
wenn es darum geht die Ukraine
aufzunehmen Anne brö live aus KI vielen
Dank in Jordanien sind bei einem
drohenangriff auf einen usstützpunkt
drei amerikanische Soldaten getötet
worden 34 weitere wurden verletzt der
Angriff sei von radikalen vom Iran
unterstützten militanten Gruppen verübt
worden erklärte US-Präsident Biden seit
Monaten greifen die Milizen immer wieder
US-Truppen im Nahen Osten an hintergrund
ist der Krieg zwischen Israel und der
Hamas im
Gazastreifen nach schweren Vorwürfen
gegen Mitarbeiter des un-hilfswerks für
palästinensische Flüchtlinge hat nun
auch Deutschland seine Zahlungen vorerst
eingestellt es bestehe der Verdacht dass
zwlf Beschäftigte am Massaker der Hamas
in Israel am 7 Oktober beteiligt waren
un-gensekretär guterisch appellierte an
die Geberländer weit Gelder zur
Verfügung zu stellen jeder Schuldige
Mitarbeiter werde zur Rechenschaft
gezogen ein dreiviertel Jahr nach dem
Beitritt zur NATO Welt Finnland einen
neuen Präsidenten ersten Hochrechnungen
zufolge führt der frühere konservative
Regierungschef stup vor dem grünen
exaußenminister h visto die endgültige
Entscheidung wird allerdings erst in
einer Stichwahl im Februar fallen alle
Kandidaten haben eine harte Haltung
gegenüber Russland angekündigt
und jetzt sind wir schon beim Handball
Norbert aus der Traum von einer
deutschen Medaille bei der Heim ja
schade aber wie schon zuvor im
verlorenen Halbfinalspiel gegen Dänemark
hat das dabteam erneut eine starke
Leistung gezeigt zum Schluss eine
rasante Aufholjagd gegen permanent
führende Schweden reichtte aber nicht
ein hochemotionales Spiel um Platz 3 im
Blickpunkt beide Torhüter Schweden der
fünfmalige Europameister in dunklen
Trikots entpuppt sich als der
übermächtige Gegner ab der vierten
Minute läuft Deutschland im Rückstand
hinterher Weltklasse der Schwede Andreas
palika 19 Paraden Deutschland zu schwach
im Angriff und immer wieder eiskalte
Konter der Schweden Pausenstand 18: 122
Deutschland holt bis zu fünf Tore
Rückstand auf aber eben nicht mehr am
Ende 34 Z 31 für Schweden Bronze und das
Olympia Ticket dass ich Deutschland nun
über ein weiteres Qualifikationsturnier
erst noch holen
muss der Sieger der Australien Open
heißt Jannick Sinner er gewann das
hartumkämpfte Finale in fünf Sätzen
gegen den Russen Daniel medweldev der
erste Grand Slam Sieg des Italieners zum
Abschluss der
rodelheimwm in Altenberg hat Julia
taubitz im klassischen einsätzer Silber
gewonnen und in der Team Staffel holte
man sogar do das deutsche setit gewann
vor den USA und Lettland insgesamt gab's
sieben deutsche Medaillen darunten
darunter dreimal Gold
bei der skiflug WM in Bad Mitterndorf
haben die deutschen Springer Bronze
geholt und zwear im Teamwettbewerb das
DSV Quartett in der Besetzung Pius
Paschke Karl Geiger Stefan lei und hier
im Bild Andreas Wellinger musste sich
nur Slowenien und Österreich
geschlagen erneute Erfolge auch beim Bob
Weltcup in Lillehammer im Zweier der
Frauen siegten Kim kaliki und Leon
fiebeck Laura nolter und Nele Schuten
wurden zweite Doppelerfolg auch bei den
Männern im Vierer Bob ein packendes
deutsches Duell zwischen Francesco
Friedrich und seinem Dauerrivalen
Johannes Lochner sein Team am Ende mit
22 h Abstand auf Platz 2 der dritte
Saisonsieg für Friedrich im großen
Schlitten ja und übrigens auch Lochner
mit
37 das war's vom Sport am Sonntag ja
praller Wintersport vielen Dank fehlt
noch der Blick aufs Wetter oft ist es
sonnig im Norden und in der Mitte gibt
es allerdings auch hohe Wolken im Süden
anfangs zum Teil Nebel 6 bis
14° das heute journal um :4 Uhr mit
Christian Sievers morgen übernimmt hier
Mitri Sirin das ganze 19 Uhr Team
wünscht Ihnen einen guten Start in die
neue Woche wir freuen uns jetzt auf die
Premiere von Daniel ponzen bei Berlin
direkt